mais cette fois nous allons le faire par nous-mêmes
à l'ère guro Twitter ela
[Applaudissements]
tu peux m'appeler une [ __ ] si tu veux
ça va
je m'en fiche tu peux m'appeler
comme tu veux
tu peux regarder mon corps ou c'est  grossier
j'ai causé ça ou je ne veux
plus jamais revoir ça mais la seule chose que tu fais c'est de
me toucher sans mon consentement tu dois faire
avec moi
tu as le droit de changer qu'on
s'habille là où il y a un booty short et
un débardeur mais  que ce soit ta
fille préférée, va te lever, nous
avons le droit de choisir comment nous identifions
et exprimons notre genre si c'est
conforme aux mœurs sociales
ce que nous faisons quoi que
tu ordonnes de changer avec qui nous avons des
relations sexuelles et toi  danse tu es content que
tu dises non
[Musique]
le 9 octobre 2012 les talibans
ont raccourci le côté gauche de mon
front ils ont court mes amis aussi ils
pensaient que la balle nous ferait taire
mais ils ont échoué les extrémistes étaient et
ils sont  peur des livres et des stylos le
pouvoir de l'éducation le pouvoir de
l'éducation leur fait peur ils ont peur
des femmes le pouvoir de la voix des femmes
leur fait peur aujourd'hui je me concentre sur les
droits des femmes dans l'éducation des filles
car ce sont elles qui souffrent le plus
il fut un temps  lorsque des
militantes sociales ont demandé aux hommes de défendre
leurs droits, mais cette fois nous le ferons
par nous-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes recherches récentes m'ont montré que le
féminisme est devenu un mot impopulaire que
les femmes choisissent de ne pas  pour m'identifier comme
féministes apparemment je fais partie des
rangs des femmes dont les expressions sont
considérées comme trop fortes trop agressives
isolantes et anti-hommes peu attirantes même
pourquoi le mot est devenu si
inconfortable je viens de Grande Bretagne et
je pense qu'il est juste  payé le
même que mes homologues masculins, je pense qu'il
est juste que je puisse prendre
des décisions concernant mon propre corps si vous
croyez en l'égalité, vous pourriez être l'une de
ces féministes par inadvertance dont j'ai parlé
plus tôt et pour cela je vous applaudis nous
sommes  luttant pour un mot fédérateur mais
la bonne nouvelle c'est que nous avons un
mouvement fédérateur ça s'appelle lui pour elle je
t'invite à t'avancer pour être vu
et à te demander sinon moi qui sinon
maintenant quand
merci beaucoup
[  Applaudissements]
ma mère et moi ne sommes pas d'accord sur beaucoup de
choses concernant le genre il y a
certaines choses que ma mère pense qu'une
personne devrait faire pour la simple raison
que ladite personne est une femme comme
parfois sourire du nord même quand
sourire est la dernière chose que vous voulez  faire
comme stratégiquement donné à certains
arguments, en particulier lorsque vous vous disputez avec une
non-femme comme se marier et avoir
des enfants maintenant, je peux penser à d'assez bonnes
raisons pour faire l'une de ces choses, mais
parce que vous êtes une femme
n'en fait pas partie et donc  la classe de 2015
n'accepte jamais parce que tu es une femme
comme raison de faire ou de ne rien faire
et enfin je voudrais terminer par une
dernière note sur la chose la plus importante
au monde l'amour maintenant les filles sont souvent
élevées pour voir l'amour comme  seules les femmes données
sont louées pour leur amour quand cet
amour est un acte de donner mais l'amour est
de donner et de prendre s'il vous plaît aimez en
donnant et en prenant donnez et soyez donné si
vous ne faites que donner et ne pas prendre vous
savez que vous saurez de  cette petite et
vraie voix à l'intérieur de vous que nous, les femmes,
sommes si souvent socialisées pour faire taire ne faites pas
taire cette voix osez prendre
le premier garçon qui m'a tenu la main les seuls
garçons ne veulent pas entendre parler de vagins qui
saignent jeune
misogynie vagins uniquement destinés à être baisés
seins uniquement destinés à être sciés marques
uniquement destinées à souffler - je sais que ma taille
était censée être comparée à un sablier ma
voix ne voulait que trembler s'il vous plaît
vite mais je suis réduit au silence car
déjà Boyd sur son sexuel
interaction pas seulement moi mes
amies ma mère sœurs accélèrent toutes le rythme
après 20h30 le soir donc je porte mes
jeans longs et porte mes hauts hauts ne
montre pas mon décolleté ou un soupçon de mes cuisses
je ne veux pas être confondu avec  le vouloir
parce que si j'étais moins je ne fais pas que l'
afficher je le risque c'est le
roi de ma virginité mais ma vie mon
hymen semble être secret ou garder
Attila et ma femme sinon je suis une
[ __ ] accapareuse  et skank et plus pas aussi sûr
qu'avant à l'âge de 10 ans mes robinets en laiton
de lignes sexuelles en même temps nous
n'obtenons pas de [ __ ] de droits sexuels
ma tante violée par un mari mais le
viol conjugal c'est bien c'est un fou  conception
obtenez une ligne
donc ce que j'essaie de dire ici ce soir,
c'est que je suis désolé d'avoir été élevé dans une
famille où mon frère m'a appris le mal
de là où ma mère croit en
notre génération pour améliorer le monde et
le rendre un peu plus facile  pour
chaque fille,
j'étais tellement excitée à 13 ans lorsque le film est
sorti et que mon travail et mon art
auraient une réponse humaine J'ai ouvert avec enthousiasme
mon premier courrier de fan pour lire un fantasme de viol
qu'un homme m'avait écrit un compte à rebours
a commencé le  mon émission de radio locale à mon
18e anniversaire par euphémisme la date à
laquelle je serais autorisé à coucher avec des
critiques de films a parlé de mes seins en herbe
et des critiques j'ai compris très
vite même à treize ans
que si je devais m'exprimer
sexuellement je le ferais  ne me sens pas en sécurité et que les
hommes se sentiraient en droit de discuter et d'
objectiver mon corps à mon grand
inconfort la réponse à mon expression
allant de petits commentaires sur mon corps à des
déclarations délibérées plus menaçantes
sert à contrôler mon comportement dans un
environnement de terrorisme sexuel un monde
dans lequel  Je pourrais porter ce que je veux,
dire ce que je veux et exprimer mon
désir comme je le veux sans craindre
pour ma sécurité physique ou ma réputation,
ce serait le monde dans lequel
le désir et la sexualité féminins pourraient avoir leur
plus grande expression et leur plus grand épanouissement.
ce que je veux c'est ce dont j'ai besoin c'est ce que
je désire c'est comment vous pouvez m'aider à procurer du
plaisir aux personnes de tous
les genres ici avec nous aujourd'hui trouvons un
espace où nous nous occupons mutuellement d'un commun accord du
plaisir de l'autre et
permettons le vaste illimité  gamme de désir
à exprimer faisons une révolution
du désir
es el siglo los derechos de la mujeres
masterda más temprano la joven que por
tener sumo Chili's los palos verdes interdiction de
kita los derechos bon citron
s'ensuit Eidos esta el poder de votar por
nuestro derechos  no le tme bleh el pulso
para ser lo sakti mozella clandestine
Adal aborto legisla Mo's por la salud
e-poll autonomie de las mujeres a las
horas para la really mujeres que vou
para que la selva politique cantines
Unni le différentiel central l'
ère guro tweto c'est  le LA
vous